English
Samantha what are you doing here I'm not
Samantha you are you have a 5 30
appointment with John Mandy at the John
Mandy Salon go fans are eagerly
anticipating the return of Samantha
Jones as Kim Cattrall is set to reprise
her iconic role for a special cameo in
season two of and just like that but it
seems that the stars of the series have
some concerns in a new interview with
Sunday time style Cynthia Nixon shared a
warning about her Cameo saying this I
worry that with all the buildup people
are going to wonder what all the fuss
was about it's important to know that it
is a very brief very small Cameo I don't
know what to say I can't believe it well
neither can I but here I am now Kim
initially refused to start in the
rebooted series following her Feud with
co-star Sarah Jessica Parker however
earlier this year the post confirmed
that the actress would be stepping back
into Samantha's shoes for the season two
finale Cynthia added we were very
disappointed that the secret leaves of
Kim's upcoming appearance so hoped it
was something people wouldn't know about
until they saw the episode and that it
would be a fun surprise as they were
watching meanwhile Sarah Jessica Parker
addressed the big return during a recent
appearance on the Howard Stern Show we
should mention even though uh you know
Kim Cattrall will be making his Academy
chef's kiss a little
okay A little soup song
they must offered her a bundle of dough
but she's back and SJP also opened up on
the return of actor John Corbett who
played Carries On Again off-again
boyfriend Aiden in in the city
but maybe not everything
it's an affectionate relationship yeah
yeah
they're very tactile they're very
physical those two